Indians get a way longer leash than
anybody else as they should yes that's
your job is to talk [ __ ] modern day
philosophy and even if it's kind of
bombastic and ridiculous and out there
and totally extreme it's like this is
jokes yeah and this is I was talking to
uh Jordan Peterson about this recently
but like it's the importance of play
it's like human beings we like to play
with the things that we're uncomfortable
with that we we fear right like
Halloween the whole idea of Halloween is
playing with death like we're terrified
of dying we're terrified of like our
parents dying our children God forbid
dying so we have a whole holiday which
we didn't used to dress up as like
football players used to be like
skeletons and that kind of [ __ ] it was
like let's play with this thing we're
terrified we can do it with uh when you
go to like a Disney World or some [ __ ]
you go on these roller coasters you're
terrified of it but we've and that's
what comedy really is it's playing with
emotions that scare us ideas that scare
us and doing it in a way where we can
all laugh and experience it in a safe
way so when it happens in real life
we're a little bit more ready and that's
why it's existed for [ __ ] talking
probably thousands of years people been
busting balls forever when you're with
your guys and you're with your guys in
the troop there's no softball jokes no
it's the most Savage thing yeah there's
no question about it
your sexuality yeah I I I haven't
obviously I haven't done any um any any
service but I wish that
I wish that people could see what the
camaraderie is in these troops because
from my understanding from my friends
who have served my father served
there's no it's like everybody loses
their identity they have outside and all
the oh you're Puerto Rican the the white
guy will say the craziest thing about a
Puerto Rican they can say the crazy
thing about a Jewish guy and it's like
dude I was I'm Middle Eastern in the
Army oh yeah yeah you're talking about
like Let It Rip well I was in 9 11.
you were in your stripes
happening people were like yo benihant
your mom and dad from where these people
are from oh my gosh [ __ ] here we go but
it was great you know because I fought
back yeah if you can if you can take it
it's really gonna build some character
if you can take it oh yeah yeah late
night two o'clock you're drunk just you
know calling each other out talking [ __ ]
yeah but if any of that was recorded
forget it forget about it I mean it's
canceled done oh but those relationships
you you have and those moments are so
beautiful because you're saying exactly
what you feel jokingly to another person
exactly you're not putting on like a
slight facade so then you get to build
these like really deep connections and
that's that's always what I've felt like
even with Comics you see that like we
say kind of whatever to one another
people I've worked with and it's like I
want to build I want to build a world
where we can be almost 100 honest with
one another because then I'm a ride for
you no matter what you're gonna ride for
me no matter what because you really
know me I'm not being a politician about
it I mean that's to be honest with Trump
I think exposed about politics he was
playful up there with a bunch of people
faking and it was so hard to not look at
them when all these other people were
trying to be like like Jeb Bush trying
to be all professional yeah and he's and
he's just Clowning Jeb yeah he's like
look how far down you are that was
amazing because they wake up yeah wake
up you're taking a nap because he's a
comedian I think what you're talking
about because I did stand up comedy for
many years and then I got into finance
and all that but one of the things I
used to always say because I used to
make fun of this person and that person
is like it's not racist if you make fun
of everybody yeah if anybody can get it
at any given time it's not racist you're
just talking [ __ ] the thing with Kanye
is nope it's just the juice I was like
well then you're just an anti-semite and
you're a Jew hater and there's no jokes
and there's no jokes there either that's
why it's not that funny
yeah
you know that choose control the media
and going off what you said Adam so and
I think the beauty like and going off
where you said uh Andrew was infamous is
the the special that you did which was
[ __ ] don't it was bananas
to want a compliment to open just what
real comedy is and this is real and I
know you know this and pattern them
appreciate it you opened your special
with crowd work and for all the people
that are out there this guy you're
taping this thing the money's been it
it's it's not like it's
this is a one take shot the guy walks
out he's busting this person's balls the
Latina in the front yeah and and nailing
off is what you just said yeah you hit
everybody the black guy the Mexican
chick the white guy and and I I think
it's beautiful no more number two we're
they're slowly trying to take that [ __ ]
away from us which is like yo yo time
out this actually brings us together you
[ __ ] are trying to separate us the
guys going up there on a special and
busting balls like you were in the
cellar or you wouldn't yeah and it felt
it felt like I'm like okay this dude's
having a blast and that's what I wanted
man like what I learned from from doing
comedy is that like and I'm very
fortunate that I have a very diverse
audience like white people found me
after black people and Latinos because I
started doing Guy Code and then podcasts
with Charlemagne the God do you guys
know Charlemagne yeah of course one of
the most brilliant radio personalities
in history and we're doing a podcast so
black people were the ones who came out
to my shows when I was on the road
initially blacks like Latinos and like
some white people know me from the MTV
stuff and then when I did Rogan and when
I started to have more like viral
success online that's when white people
found me so for me I was always very
comfortable also just growing up in New
York just this is how we made fun of one
another like my friend group was diverse
and we were just gonna not make fun of
Dominican kid like he's gonna get it
like everybody else so so what I've
realized is that if you're making fun of
someone to their face
and they're laughing is very hard to be
offended on their behalf
but when you're doing a joke about black
people and the black people are in the
audience yeah it's the people you know
there's Andrew it's the people that are
watching that interaction and going oh
that's right he's racist and he's like
Mitch shut up you can't even say if
she's laughing she's [ __ ] laughing at
it and you're pissed off and you're not
and you're you're you're like oh you're
a white person making you're upset about
this leave it alone so what all the
craziness taking place I believe future
looks right if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetaining it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red our
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people weren't in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bad toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
[Music]